let me ask you
what is the relevance of vladimir putin
being kicked out of the uh
removed from the world economic forum
website i mean
we're talking about financial currencies
we're talking about the world economic
forum
it feels like i've got a bunch of points
that seem like they're connected the
world economic forum the international
monetary fund the swift payment system
russia being uh you know starting a war
then being booted what's what's the
connection here i mean was russia
involved in the liberal economic order
is he not involved in that or i don't
think putin is but but but i think that
this will be an opportunity for the
introduction of it potentially could be
i should say uh for the introduction of
central banking digital currencies um
which i describe as vouchers but it's
it's if that's if it sounds like
what putin is doing is going to help
make that a reality yeah
so it sounds like
that makes it sound like it's one big
plot well you don't need to i see this
is the thing
we don't need to worry about intentions
just to understand what the consequences
of these actions are yeah yeah agree and
that's where people get stuck they get
stuck on intentions and i'm like well
it doesn't matter what putin intended if
the consequences of kicking russia out
of the swift system mean that you end up
with this financial money supply
division on the planet you then have got
these blocks eurasia and oceana
and and what that leads to is if you can
no longer trade with russian banks when
you're buying russian gas in your
germany and you can no longer buy from
russia because you can't pay them
bitcoin you
and already we see bitcoin flooding into
ukraine to fund the opposition right
now how do you control that because
one thing we do know is bitcoin isn't in
the interests of the banking
establishment so that that's where you
then where is it
well you tell me i don't i think that
what they would want to do is introduce
central banking digital currencies
that's what they've told us they want
yeah i i think there's a good
possibility uh when you look at the
prominence of bitcoin over the past 10
years
it would not be hard for a
nation to gain enough control over the
network to create faux centralization
a lot of people say oh that can't happen
i don't believe it but um what's what's
the current market cap for bitcoin do
you know is it one trillion i guess is
2.1 trillion let's find out no it's
going to be less than 1.9 trillion you
could have market manipulation right yep
you can manipulate the market there we
absolutely do china's been doing that's
1.93 trillion one point nine that's the
global market cap of all crypto right
now of all crypto so bitcoin market cap
is 832 billion 832 billion so let's go
back seven years the market cap of
crypto was substantially less
the us nato countries could have easily
bought in and controlled more than 51
percent of the bitcoin network which
would give them control over
how it works effectively it's a little
bit more complicated though i'm trying
to simplify it the fact the point is
it just requires immense
uh managerial power but from the early
stages we could see the true power of
bitcoin i've long speculated and even
told all of my crazy anarchist and
libertarian friends i'm like
what if what if you know you're buying
into bitcoin
what if that's the global currency it's
public ledger anyone can track they the
ai systems their computers they'll
figure out what your address is
in seconds and there's nothing you can
do to stop them
you know i got to tell you man i have
seen brilliant private investigatorial
work from individuals there there's a
there's a an individual who was doxed in
the uk
uh he was posting on social media how
did they find out who he was
they knew how they knew the sound of his
voice
so they looked at the average they they
took a bunch of his posts then found the
average time of posting and they said
this shows the individual is in this
region of the uk they then looked for a
person who fit key details background
age interest hobbies
a human being did all of that work
imagine what a computer can do when
you're doing transactions they'll
instantly know what part of the world
you're in from there they break it down
they know what you're buying because
they know what everyone else is buying
the bitcoin ledger is going it is it is
publicly trackable and when they talk
about zcash and monero which are two
cryptos which are supposedly secure we
learned that the fbi was able to track
monero payments when they arrested that
that woman crocodile of wall street lady
yeah i i think there's i'm not saying
i'm a big fan of bitcoin so you're
you're talking about the um
the privacy concerns on the ledger but
what you still can't do is control the
supplier you can manipulate the price
you can control the supply of bitcoin
it's called the 51 attack if you control
it more no i mean the the overall amount
of bitcoin in the world once once it's
hit it's um maximum cap right you can't
just print more bitcoin once that's done
right right right bitcoin like fiat
currency but um with a 51 percent attack
you can effectively do anything you want
yeah so if you control more than half of
the nodes
then you basically tell the the fork
what to do now of course if you go too
hard you'll create a hard fork and it'll
split the the blockchain in half we've
seen that happen on accident before to
what i'm saying is i don't know if it's
true a lot of people say no tim calm
down this could never happen but if the
us and western powers
or even china and russia bought in very
very early on and have maintained growth
of their of their uh bitcoin nodes they
could absolutely control more than half
the network which gives them control of
the entirety of the system so i think
what you're describing is the um
compared to what can be done with fiat
money in a in a sovereign nation
is probably a less worse case scenario
than what we currently have with the
control of the money supply that's right
horrible what's going on right now they
can print 800 billion of fiat and then
just buy all the bitcoin now there's
there's also concerns about um quantum
computing being able to crack private
keys in which case the system is just a
facade
that that though could be met so quant
if when we reach quantum power in that
way and it's sustainable i think you you
also end up with quantum encryption that
can actually
so you the technology improves in its
encryption capabilities not just in its
hacking capabilities exactly quantum
resistance
right yeah so so um
the the bitcoin community that all the
people involved could choose to hard
fork on purpose with new resilience and
new technology i will say this it is my
personal opinion that bitcoin will
become a dominant global standard for
exchange and store of value in some
meaningful way i've i've long thought
that was the case and that's why i've
said how do you know this is not the
global currency that that's something
they want but i'll put it i'll put it
very simply i've long said i believe one
bitcoin will become worth a million
dollars equivalent buying power
i believe we're on track for that i
don't know exactly when or how but i do
believe that and i have certainly bought
my share of bitcoin and cryptocurrencies
because i truly believe it i'm not
telling anybody what to do i'm saying
what i've done i believe there comes a
time we're watching what's happening in
russia every incentive is being given to
them to back their financial markets
using bitcoin as the facilitation
mechanism or yeah that's the consequence
of what's happening or a central bank
token which is worse than well it's
different than a crypto because it's not
on a blockchain it's just a central bank
they have it on a ledger but it's a
digital currency that they can track
it's uh
disaster i know because i could tell you
from there this is what i'm worried
about because i could say right
uh
you're not going to buy meat this week
you've had your quota which you can't
even if you can manipulate the bitcoin
uh price if you control 51
what you can't do is say right you can't
use the tiny bit of bitcoin that you own
to buy that meat you have to buy bugs it
depends on if they can gain control of
the exchanges which they mostly can
so uh
if people are i'll put it this way they
can ban your address from sending or
receiving through certain exchanges so
they can say all of our financial
institutions and mechanism the companies
that facilitate the exchange we won't
allow it but the blockchain still exists
which means you could easily find
someone who just says i'll do a direct
adjustment transfer outside they could
do something like a centrally controlled
economy could do something where if you
have crypto you have to buy nfts as
vouchers and then you use those nfts for
specific things so you can only use
those nfts for food for liquor for
that
the currency would need to be fungible
but they can control the system it
doesn't need to be you know unique
tokens specifically right i think this
is the this is the so we've got the
chancellor of exchequer in the uk rishi
sunak openly declaring this uh uh uh
that that as the leader of the g7
they're going to introduce central
banking digital currencies right and
these as this is what i'm calling as
vouchers
and uh you so the fiat money pretty much
at some stage is going to come to an end
and what you've described as the
potential dangers and pitfalls of
bitcoin
specifically or crypto generally i still
think is a least worst case scenario
when you can consider what can happen i
agree with cbdc it sounds like i just
want to say real quick um i'm i'm sort
of playing devil's advocate on the
potential risks of bitcoin i genuinely
think it's it's better it's i think it's
fantastic and i think it's going to
become a million dollars per bitcoin
it's good that you're doing it because
it's like don't let a crisis go to waste
and what's happening is the bankers are
looking at bitcoin as a crisis and
they're trying to make sure that they
can turn it into an opportunity just
like joe biden encouraged us to do last
night on this in his campaign speech
mm-hmm they called it a state of the
union but it was just can't campaign
speech at the very end was like and what
by the way the state of the union the
state of the union is strong
the state of the union is strong because
the people are strong and strong strong
stronger
and we're going to end cancer do you see
that joke where you gotta watch it at
the end of the day at the end he says go
get him and everyone's like what like
what does that mean yeah who who who's
that and then he's inciting an
insurrection someone that's what during
the standing ovation wasn't it
yeah and then someone uh someone i think
from the daily wire said that was just
the part that of the of the prompter
that biden wasn't supposed to read it
was instructions to his handlers
go get him that's hilarious we were
debating if he said uh when he was
saying the ukrainian people at one point
he said the uranium people and people
like
iranians the closest iranian the closest
real word to the sound he made is
iranian but it sounded like uranium so i
was making fun of uranus i i think
you're right that's how i say it he said
iranian russia will never get the hearts
and minds of the of the iranian people
the iranian people no one has never said
never outside kiev but here's here's
here's the important oh yeah i want to
talk back about him split in the
comments why why do we believe he meant
to say ukrainian
who
is the person who gets to decide what
joe biden really meant
if joe biden so he was meeting with the
g7 and he said you know we got you know
troops in libya we're going to be
sending military he meant syria
what would happen what would happen if
joe biden's in you know an uh a
situation room meeting and he's like uh
we we gotta send these weapons to the
iranian people and then someone was like
are you mr president are you sure yeah
we're gonna we're gonna send 30 billion
dollars some uh some fighter jets to to
the iranian people and they'll go
whatever you say sir i'll make it happen
and then breaking news iran receives
massive payload of cash from us
government dude it's not even a joke but
hold on imagine the alternative joe
biden says we're going to send a pallet
of cash to the ukrainian people and
someone goes he meant iranian people and
then they decide for themselves and
exactly when they when it's hitting the
fan and it's wartime make a decision now
and he says the wrong word that's death
but that's why it's so dangerous to have
a president that effectively is mentally
impaired no and he actually no we were
talking about the most polite way of
ever it's a very polite way of putting
it and we were sort of joking about this
the other day we were watching his state
of the union poking fun at him it is
actually genuinely sad the fact that we
were all
talking about this after the show this
is probably the best speech he's given
in his entire presidency and he's
slurring every single word he sounds
intoxicated
yeah and that's as good as it gets i
mean i remember for him when trump would
give speeches and make such mistakes
there would be viral videos exactly and
they were never even close to as bad as
biden's mistakes like biden's best and
i'm not saying trump didn't have some
gaps but like biden's best day is what
we saw yesterday and he sounded drunk he
really did i'm not trying to be mean
yeah and if anyone's gonna come at me
and say that that's really insensitive
to say about the president of the united
states you are acknowledging that he did
sound like that
oh that's a good point
he did realistically now i want to just
touch back on ukraine really quick so
you think that he's going to try and i
think i've been thinking almost every
day he's going to split the country in
half on that river yeah that reservoir
you know what the name of the river is i
can't figure it out such a reservoir
is upper river but who knows papa but
there's the east and the west right so
the side that's on the russian side
that's the east of that river we'll
probably go to look i say probably let's
hope there's no world war three right so
if look ultimately putin's gone in there
now and he's not just going to leave
that right he's gone in there for a
reason for whatever reason
so probably this is the the outcome that
it will end on which is that you'd end
up with a split ukraine
and kiev like the kievan ruse i think
that was the history of the russians was
kievan kievan ruse yeah and it's in his
backyard right so
you know bayer pigs i mean america's
done all of this stuff
iran contra affair
you know i know i wanna i wanna speak
out against it but like to sit in
silence while my brethren are conquering
and kicking doors in in iraq is i don't
know if they're still doing that but
they were if our president is uh as you
described it mentally impaired yes can't
speak straight
how is he going to prevent russia from
doing whatever it is russia intends to
do
is it because if someone else is in
charge no but he's not going to
he's if you know what has he done
i mean look well they cancelled this
icbm test which is
in some ways good but that's not
preventing russia that's just not
escalating a conflict right which is
good by the way i'm happy but
no one's going to stop what putin's
decided to do unless you want war with
putin and this is the problem that
you've got an option right now putin
went in and called everybody's bluff
now either we engage directly with
russia and that's world war three which
i don't think is a good idea
in particular because we don't have the
moral high ground you know our own
countries have gone and invaded
countries
and when we went into iraq and
afghanistan the last thing we expected
um was for russia to attack us directly
because we invaded iraq or afghanistan
you know what narrative i really love
yeah there's a story coming out where it
said vladimir putin believed the
invasion would last only 15 days and the
government would collapse and they would
come in and it would be clean and i was
like yeah yeah and we thought we'd be
greeted as liberators
the same same narrative this is it it
says people are very very out of touch
and they they
i find it amazing how um there is now
almost it's expected that we take a line
on this that is
this word jingoism right it's very
jingoistic line that we're expected to
take almost as if we must
uh back direct
action against against russia thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there
you